hi everyone its Johanna here and if
you're like most women I am sure that
our certain paths in your body which you
like to reduce such as your thighs your
waist size or your arms and for some of
you there might be certain parts in your
body which you like to enlarge like your
breasts your bum or even your legs so in
this video we'll be discovering what
body types you are and how can we
customize your workout in order to suit
your body type apparently there are six
different body types the apron the v3
the H spring the rule afraid the eighth
frame and the oval frame so let's go
through the first body type which is the
a frame which is also known as a spoon
frame generally people with a frame
carry extra weight and the lower region
of their body if you have bigger legs
bigger hips bigger bumps in comparison
to your upper body where your breasts
and weights are smaller in size then you
are the a frame and for a frame the
teleport you can do is to firm it fast
and do a lot of color for the lower part
of your body so workout my squats lunges
are
for you and remember to do them in high
raps because whenever you do work in
high rep so that's when you will first
fell off hand tuna where as what you
want to be doing for your upper body is
to do for your muscles slightly more in
order to balance it up with a little
body so do shoulder press do chest
workout do all your biceps triceps
workout or remember to put heavier
weights and to reduce your repetition
when you pack a lot of weights that's
when you would do muscles and put a
slightly bigger prey before your upper
body so that's the a-frame and the
second body type is the V frame and
that's the opposite of the a-frame so
you might notice that you have bigger
boobs you know your upper body is
basically heavier than your lower body
you might notice that you have small
legs small bumps whereas you know your
chest and your waist is heavier on the
top and for the V frame what you want to
be doing is to do a lot of high
repetition workouts to really turn up
the upper body whereas increase the size
of your legs what you want to be
focusing is to really do quality thigh
exercises so squats lunges leg presses I
remember to pack the weights on and to
do it between 6 to 8 reps and if you
find that easy
that means you to put more weight
your lips that is the way to increase
muscle size and the third body type is
the hitch frame the H frame lady has an
athletic body but with proto shoulders
and rotor waist and like symmetry so for
those of you who are hitch frame you
might notice that the width of your show
that anyways looks almost the same what
you want to be doing is to add
definition to your waist and to reduce
the size of your shoulders slightly and
the workout that you want to be focusing
on is upper body workout abs workout but
to really tone it up instead of
increasing your muscle size so workouts
like show depressed push-ups are really
good to really tone up your upper body
and don't forget to work on your abs
workouts like brushing twist or you know
sit up and twist those work are really
good to work on the site muscles to give
you a nice definition on your waist and
the next item is the ruler body shape if
you are a ruler shape you will notice
that the measurement from the top to the
bottom of your body is straight
generally you are thin and you find it
very difficult to put on weight for
people who
a ruler shape what you want to avoid
doing too much is cardio exercises
because what you don't want to be doing
is to put more fat or put a muscle off
which you already do not have so really
focus on good quality total body
strength training remember in order to
increase muscle size or to put on weight
if that is your goal what you want to be
doing is to really pack on the weights
and do low repetitions so between six to
eight repetitions for eight to ten to
begin with and if you find that easy
remember that you need to put on more
weight in order to make it work out
harder that is the way to increase
muscle size as well as game in size and
the fifth body type is the eighth frame
which is also known as the hourglass
generally the measurement of their bus
and their hips are almost similar and
their ways are a lot smaller
according to model experts if your waist
is 10 inches smaller than your hips or
your bus that is the perfect figure for
people with hourglass frame you do put
on you can put on weight but if you were
to workout you will find that it is very
easy way to lose weight as well so as
long as you do workout moment
healthy lifestyle and in a good cardio
and meant in a strength workout you
should find it fairly easy to maintain
your size but if you don't do any sort
of workout you will find that you will
put on weight but then again is very
easy for you to do it as well
okay so generally a nice avocado is fine
keep your cardio duration between 20 to
30 minutes and do strength workout
alternate between high repetitions so in
15 to 20 and after 4 weeks you can
change your exercise program to have
your strength training in order to
define your muscles and the last body
frame is the oval frame so people with
open frame usually finds it really
difficult to lose weight they are
generally champion so what you want to
be focusing on is along cardio workouts
to put the fat off and to focus on high
repetition strength work up to really
put the fat of increase
hold up if you can keep into 30 minutes
really work on the cardio and work on
your strength for another 30 minutes
high repetition push yourself as hard as
you can and always keep your heart rate
up because the higher your heart rate is
the more fat you burn and most
importantly don't forget to watch over
your nutrition of what you eat when you
take will affect your weight so those
are the six different basic body types
and the workout they will be good for
you so let me know a body shape you are
and I think I'm quite likely to be an
a-frame or at least I want to be an
a-frame because I can put away but I
find it easy for me to lose to it as
well as as long as I'm being good so
leave your comments and let me know what
body shape you are and don't forget to
subscribe to my You Tube page share this
video and like this video
you